[музика]
Великобританія Франція
Німеччина Італія
за лічені дні президент Володимир
Зеленський здійснив цілий тур Європою
Відвідавши спочатку несподіваними
візитами головних партнерів України Як
пояснив сам Зеленський його закордонні
візити серед іншого були присвячені
створенню коаліції країн-партнерів у
межах якої в Україні будуть надані
винищувачі західного зразка Про це він
заявив під час спілкування з
представниками ЗМІ за результатами
переговорів із федеральним канцлером
Німеччини олафом шольцем у Берліні та Чи
вдалося зеленському досягнути своїх
цілей
[музика]
візит українського президента до
Німеччини став знаковим з огляду на не
найпростіші відносини між Києвом і
берліном і це при тому що Німеччина
стала одним із ключових постачальників
зброї в Україні та прийняла Понад
мільйон біженців
ми знаємо що німецько-українські
відносинам завдано шкоди німецькою
політикою наявна серйозна втрата довіри
до Німеччини яка виникла через одуже
повільні постачання зброї через не
найвдалішу інформаційну політику в тому
числі і з боку канцлера
так минулої весни німецьке громадськість
вимагала а федеральний уряд заволікав як
у питаннях санкцій так і в питаннях
постачання зброї союзники та тодішній
посол України Андрій Мельник жорстко
критикували Берлін за нерішучість А
українська сторона навіть відмовилася
приймати у Києві президенти Німеччини
штайнмаєра через його нібито лояльне
ставлення до Росії
тепер же Німеччина відправляє в Україну
сучасні танки та системи ППО навчає
українських військових поводитися із
західними системами озброєнь
загальна сума військової допомоги з боку
ФРН вже перевищила 1 млрд євро
відносини України та Німеччини за
останні місяці покращилися після того як
Німеччина оголосила про готовність
надати Україні танке леопард-2 останньою
моделі а також системи ППО Іріс тем та
Зенітні установки гепард і цим серйозно
підтримати збройні сили України думаю що
Зеленський після того конфлікту з
президентом штайнмаєром розуміє
наскільки важлива Німеччина і наскільки
ключову роль у ЄС вона грає щоб
мобілізувати допомогу з боку ще більшої
кількості країн без Німеччини Це було б
неможливо
Про те що Німеччина зрештою стала
локомотивом Європи у справі постачання
ЗСУ зброї засвідчив новий масштабний
пакет військової допомоги Україні про
який у Берліні оголосили напередодні
візиту Зеленського йдеться про ще 30
танків леопард та додатково 20
бронетранспортерів Мардер окрім
бронетехніки ЗСУ отримає 18 колісних
гаубиць ще чотири системи повітряної
оборони айресті 12 пускових установок та
сотні керованих ракет у списку також до
200 розвідувальних безпілотників 100
броньованих бойових машин і понад 100
машин
логістичної підтримки все аби посилити
ЗСУ весь цей пакет військової допомоги
Берлін обіцяє надати у найближчі тижні
та місяці загальна вартість озброєння
близько двох мільярдів 700 мільйонів
євро Все буде взято не із запасів
бундесверу а спеціально закуплено для
азсу за даними видання шпігель-пакету
згодили під час секретних переговорів
між міністерствами та відомством
федерального канцлера акцент військової
допомоги зробили на посилення сухопутних
військ та модернізацію протиповітряної
оборони України
тож під час свого візиту до Берліна
Володимир Зеленський щиро подякував
Німеччині любому олафу як він тепер
називає канцлера Шульца та німецькому
народові за найпотужніший пакет допомоги
від початку вторгнення РФ зауваживши що
Німеччина є надійним союзником щоправда
прагнення отримувати винищувачі для ЗСУ
олафшольт коментувати не став ухилившись
від прямих запитань журналістів
нові пакети військової допомоги Києву
пообіцяли і в Парижі вони включатимуть
засоби пгу і десятки броньованих машин і
легких танків про це стало відомо зі
спільною заявою президентів України та
Франції до еммануеля макрона Зеленський
полетів відразу з Німеччини
найближчими тижнями Франція проведе
підготовкою оснастить кілька батальйонів
десятками броньованих машин і легких
танків включно з imx-10rсі крім того
Франція зосереджує свою зусилля на
підтриманні можливостей протиповітряної
оборони України щоб захистити Її
населення від ударів Росії
крім національного внеску Франція бере
активну участь у заходах Європейського
Союзу та НАТО щодо підготовки
українських військових хочу Парижі
виключають поставку будь-яких бойових
літаків до Києва проте Франція готова
вже зараз розпочати підготовку
українських пілотів у цьому Емануель
макрон запевнив уже Наступного дня після
зустрічі з Зеленським
зустріч з прем'єр-міністром
Великобританії ріші сунаком стало
завершальною в Європейському турі
Зеленського однак саме оголошення
напередодні та в її межах поставки мають
неабияке значення в довгостроковій
перспективі йдеться передусім про
далекобійні ракети з Том Shadow з
радіусом ураження приблизно 250
кілометрів
здатні нести боєприпас вагою приблизно
450 кілограмів ці ракети схожі з
характеристиками з американськими
ейтеками наземного базування про які
давно просить Київ крім того
Великобританія надасть сотні ракет
протиповітряної оборони а також нових
безпілотних авіаційних систем в тому
числі сотні нових ударних безпілотників
дальнього радіо судії
Сполучене Королівство оголосило про
надання крилатих ракет Storm Shadow що
дійсно говорить про зміну потужностей ще
одне оголошення який ймовірно є більш
значущим на військовому фронті це кілька
сотень безпілотників цікаво те що це
частина програми яку Великобританії
розробляє для швидкої реалізації Вони
мають велику дальність 200 км а це
по-перше надасть Україні здатність
завдавати ударів далеку за лінії
розташування військ РФ але що ще
важливіше У стратегічному плані
оголошення про поставки з торрент Shadow
британський крилатих ракет та
безпілотників чинуть тиск на США щоб
вони почали надавати свої ракети великою
дальності так само як раніше британські
поставки 14 танків челенджер торували
шлях європейським та американським
Танкам тож це насправді суттєвий крок з
точки зору здатності України
Лондон також заявив про готовність
принаймні сприяти наданню ЗСУ
винищувачів f16 у самої Великобританії
їх на озброєнні немає а вже влітку
британці розпочнуть анонсовану ще в
лютому підготовку українських пілотів
для використання ними західних бойових
літаків
навіть якщо ніщо з обіцяних нових
поставок не встигне надійти ЗСУ до
початку очікуваного контрнаступу Євротур
Зеленського Можна оцінювати яку успіх
вважають опитані ДВ експерти адже його
головною метою було передусім
забезпечення сталості військової
підтримки і поставок техніки з боку
європейських партнерів
це важливий візити не тільки тому що
Президент Зеленський зміцнює особисті
стосунки з канцлером шольцем президентом
макроном та прем'єр-міністром сунуком
але й тому що він виступає на публіці в
цей країнах перед німецькими та
британськими платниками податків
які вже багато з їхньої точки зору
зробили для підтримки України і вони
бачать Зеленського очують його слова
подяки і це безумовно допоможе йому
отримати подальшу підтримку
я був в Україні кілька тижнів тому слухи
в українських командувачів і політичних
лідерів і вони роблять фокус нам
сталості поставок на тому щоб зберегти
підтримку Я навіть інформацію що Україна
планує інші наступи після цього навесні
влітку якщо це можна так назвати і для
цього звичайно їм знадобиться
безперебійний постачання
найцікавіше в цій поїздці що Зеленський
відвідав цілу низку Європейських столиць
таким чином продемонструвавши що велика
четвірка найбільших економічно-потужних
європейських країн готові надавати
підтримку Україні не лише в
короткостроковій а й у середньостроковій
перспективі підтримати ймовірно не один
очікуваний Контрнаступ
сам Зеленський залишився задоволений
своїм європейським турне хоч і не
повернувся в Україну з винищувачами за
словами президента Україна і західні
партнери ще мають трохи попрацювати над
передачею західних винищувачів оглядачів
вважають вірогідність поставок заходом
бойових літаків високою дотиж варто
використовувати час для підготовки перш
ніж поспіхом ти у Контрнаступ радять
експерти
підготовка військових частин які повинні
будуть здійснити цей Контрнаступ це
вимагає часу розумного використовувати
цей час насамперед для підготовки
солдатів у них буде лише одна можливість
і розумно відпрацювати взаємодію між
різними видами зброї якнайкраще а також
берегти ресурси доти поки не буде
достатньо Для успішного наступу
Контрнаступ не буде раптовим і
блискавичним розуміють західні партнери
України вони готові і надалі допомагати
Україні розв'язанні Росією війни